are you looking to return to the  Commonwealth maybe you put down fallout  4 due to some game breaking quest bug  don't worry there's a big patch coming  to the game this week the update is  already available for PC players but  vault dwellers on ps4 and xbox one will  get it very soon some PC specific  features have been added like an ambient  occlusion setting and debris effects but  the real changes here are stability  improvements and bug fixes if you  encountered a weird glitch that made you  teleport while aiming a weapon that's  being fixed same goes for the glitch  that causes you to become dismembered  while still alive although honestly that  sounds less like a glitch and more like  a nightmare there are plenty of gameplay  and quest bugs being squashed and we've  got the full patch notes at gamespot  we'll let you know when the patch hits  consoles and for all the fallout news  you need you're already in the right  place  you